hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to other
edition of ask Evan today i'm answering
a question from one of my readers rich
who wrote in asking about feedback for
his website so i just launched something
new hoping to get some feedback on it
you got the time it's at the marketing
agency com side project that's about
helping businesses and organizations
reach more than ideal customers who the
search social and mobile marketing open
any criticisms may have I got a thick
skin and my therapist is on retainer
alright so let's check out the site and
see what kind of feedback we can give
now I'm a little bit delayed in
responding so my apologies they're rich
at first glance I like the site it's got
a great theme to it reach more your
ideal customers I guess the call to
action here is to get people to sign up
for this newsletter here but it looks
professionally done I like the logo
marking agents with Rich Brooks and
let's scroll down see what else we have
here we got a white paper great easy to
get people on your your list feature
dispatches search social mobile great
well I like the homepage a lot it's good
my only thoughts here maybe improvements
is you're trying to get people on to
this newsletter list and if they haven't
heard of you before or haven't heard of
the marketing agency for then people
might be a little skeptical so I know
you've done a lot of work in the past
with your writing and so you know
include that you've been own fast
company that you've been interviewed in
various publications you've written
various publications have some kind of
social proof you know if you have a lot
of likes or you know plus ones on this
page that might help a lot of people
tweeting about it or some testimonials
you know the marketing agents newsletter
was the best thing I ever read something
like that might add a little bit to it
because a lot there's so many companies
out here that are trying to target
entrepreneurs and say they can help them
with search and social and mobile and so
it can be hard to send out they've got a
really professional and catchy looking
website which is awesome but having a
little bit more proof to show that you
know there's people behind this who've
actually done a lot of work and have a
lot of
Arians and that they get results could
really entice people to want to sign up
instead of just bouncing so I you know
take a look at your bounce rate and see
how many people aren't you converting
and adding some of those things like
logos of media you've been in or
testimonials or having some kind of
social proof could really help improve
your sign up right so that's my only
thought but otherwise this page is
looking pretty good let's go check out
the blog and see what else we can find
here so six Facebook book miss worth
debunking let's load it up so we got
this is great a lot of great social
proof here is can tweeted Lincoln shared
facebook likes it's great I know rich
has awesome content so this is probably
really good and without actually going
through the the content itself we got
you know good lengthy content good
pictures subdivided well easy to read
easy to scan hold you know titles in
between looking good we got some
comments that's great I liked it is a
call to action at the end so somebody
just finds this from a google search
they'll be able to sign up again here at
the end with your name and email this
might be a little stronger if you're not
if you're still not subscribed about a
sign up box right here to make your life
easier no spam just free quality updates
to help you reach more ideal customers
you know that might that might be a
little more it might be a bit stronger
with the focus on the value that you
provide and maybe even put a testimonial
about how great the dispatches are so if
somebody has just landed on this page is
the first Oracle they've read and they
loved it and they see this call to
action it's really compelling and they
want to sign up but again you know great
content good comments if it's good
shares that would probably my only
suggestion is is making that a little
bit stronger
what else we have let's check out the
about page about the marketing agents so
a little more information about you guys
all about helping you find and engage
your audience with social search and
mobile marketing great I like the
picture I probably make it a little more
close-up it's a funky picture some
Lobster company there in the background
interesting but people do like to buy
from people so the more personal you can
make it the better and it's kind of hard
to see your face in this picture I know
you use your face a lot more with with
your Twitter account so that may be
something worth considering just zooming
in a little bit so we can see we can see
you and make it a little bit easier to
relate to you again we've got the out
this there's no I'm not sure there's a
call to action here you just have the
name and email so that might be that
might kind of stand out is a little bit
of a question mark like what's going on
here some just lands on this page more
information about you that's great you
know there's a lot of text on here um
and people may just kind of skim it and
not really get get to read all of it so
I'd probably add a little bit more of
some pictures in here so you could have
another picture of yourself doing
something else maybe you're speaking at
a conference or you know whatever it is
you're meeting somebody some kind of
action shot it's nice to have a head
shot like this is your kind of posed
formal official shot and then seeing
something of you in action at a meeting
or conference or book signing or
whatever it is that you're doing and
then maybe for some of the like it's
great you've been on ink CNN Huffington
Post put the logos on here and that
stands out a lot easier to to read and I
put that on your homepage as well or in
your header is your his header
consistent across yeah I mean as seen in
inked magazine Huffington Post CNN I put
that all across the top somewhere here
just so that when people land on any of
your pages they'll see that the people
behind this website you'll know what
they're talking about and have some
experience I said I proudly promote that
and make that front and center
otherwise the bar looks good i just add
more pictures and break it up and put
some logos in there you know if you've
been a tech expert on here maybe there's
a screenshot that you can show of you
being on TV or just show you know the
NBC logo or these logos and otherwise it
looks good you got the call to action at
the bottom again that's great you got
some social channels let's see what
you're doing on on Twitter and Google+
is a quick example so here you are now
this is great you know you got a great
close-up shot you've got an action shot
I'd put both of these on your about page
there you're very active it's great
you've got a lot of tweets and and
you're very active on it which is great
responding to people checking out the
google plus page this is more branded
for marketing agents where this seems to
me more personally branded so I don't
know if you're on google+ or what the
strategy was there from a branding point
of view you might want to try to keep
that consistent you either have a go to
a marking agents Twitter channel or a
rich brooks google+ channel this doesn't
seem that updated so we are sitting here
right now it's March 27 and the last
post on your Google+ channels februari
27 which probably doesn't look that
great you know especially if you're
somebody who's who's focusing on how
good you are at social media I know you
do a lot on Twitter so that's awesome
but you might want to keep this channel
a little more updated or if it's not
part of your plan then then shut down
the channel and don't include it on your
website because especially for somebody
who's in the business you want to make
sure that you are posting fairly
regularly across the social channels
that you promote but otherwise it looks
good congrats on a noob on the new
business I hope it's going well hope
you're adding a lot of value and look
forward to seeing the success as this
thing grows so for those of you watching
if you like this video please give it a
thumbs up I'd love to hear what you have
to think about this website in the
comments I always read those and try to
respond everybody as soon as I can and
if you have a question about your own
business or website that you want
checked out feel free to leave in the
comments below I always read those
and I'll try to make a video response
for you guys as well so thank you and
I'll see you on the next episode
you